five six nine era this year just 12
starts on the years has some injuries 61
and two thirds 52 strikeouts over 24
walks walks up for marco this year
2-2
right at the second baseman dylan moore
kind of paying attention gets back
safely but right now he needs olson to
hit a ground ball right at somebody
preferably jp crawford
and turn a double play and get out of
the inning one on one away no score
the stretch and the pitch the olson
swinging a broken back ground ball left
side of the infield charging a seeger
bare hand in the ball no play anywhere
with a shift on by the time he got there
no chance
to get olson at first base who broke his
bat and hit a squibbler to the wide open
left side of the infield and on the play
canna will get down the way to second
so two on for the yeas with one out as
olson was sawed off by a pitch broken
bat slow roller between the mount and
the third base bag and by the time
seeger got there
no chance to get anybody
that'll bring up the center fielder
raymond loreano a lot of dangerous spots
in this lineup swinging a miss beauty by
marco
big second out
slow roller
short way
out of it nicely done two stranded
so marco survives that first setting jp
crawford looking to break it over 17.
get things started for the mariners upon
our return
nobody happier to see that calendar turn
from
april and may to june and july then cole
irvine cole irwin four and one with a
two and a half just north of a two and a
half and eight starts in the months of
june and july
coming off a dandy of an outing twirled
himself a gem seven innings
seven hit shutout baseball against the
angels of anaheim one two pitch swung
out against a fast ball away two out
and that'll bring up ty france
toward right biscotti backs up and he's
got it so a good first inning for cole
irvine no score after one from seattle
chapman has really good numbers against
marco gonzalez 12 for 28
with a home run so see if he can
have a big day against gonzalez
and he's got himself a base hit toward
left center field
so one out hit
center field kelnick back kellnick
turning around it's over his head
he tracks it down chapman comes in to
score piscotty has an rbi double and the
a's get a big two out hit and it's one
nothing
that's what mark has given up to this
point mariners have one hit a two out
second inning single by tom murphy
swinging on this
marco dropped down on him there with
change in the arm angle
two and six with an era knocking on the
door of six 5.81
olsen to right
and that baby's golf another home run
for olson off of marco gonzalez that is
four in his career and the a's lead to
nothing touch it up big fella we've seen
him scoop one out of the ballpark
earlier in this series pack your bags
folks all aboard
next stop
pound town
strike three call
and right on the money hole irving was
in great shape with his pitch count but
he's jumped up to 52 pitches now he was
at 38. yeah it's the first two outs
more flight out to right he was
demo was down 02 working full flight out
round out bowers and now kyle seeger can
do some damage
base hit there we go
jp scores
coming around henniger
he scores look at the tie ball
2-10
[Applause]
and aggressive on the first pitch
looking right in the middle of the plate
and that's exactly where he gets it hits
it hard exit v low of 107.
he drives it through the infield
pick up a couple of rbis here we go two
and two
base hit memphis lead 3-2 luis terrence
checking the box again
lt with an rbi is 25th hitting streak to
seven ball games it's 3-2 mariners
all with two outs
and he's going to get a fastball
pretty much center cut 93 miles an hour
swing by trends that's right on the
barrel solid base hit two outs runners
in scoring position he's added to that
1-0 pitch
murph
little blooper lorianno good speed can
he get there no
savior scores to raise the third 4-2
murders
valiant effort by loriento but not good
enough looks like he had it for a second
and then it came out of his glove yeah
he has it glove rolls over and kind of
drops it i know they start talking about
the shape of his of of his cutter
what are you seeing with that yeah i
mean and we you know we've talked about
it quite a bit and that's a pitch that
he needs to get back online to be where
he where he was first of all i think
overall the command of it we saw that
you know the the
double to stephen piscotti that was a
cut fast one middle of the plate we just
didn't see that a couple years ago see
seth brown pinch hitting here for
biscotti
brown hits with high and deep to right
field
and that baby's goal
maybe a hit that gets the a's rolling a
solo shot to make it four to three
well what can brown do for you hit a
hanger down by two foot down and we've
seen guys spoil pitches all day long but
just unable to capitalize when they get
that cookie when they get that mistake
or two here to moreland hit the other
way base head
coming in quickly runner going to third
here's the throw
got him what a throw
what a throw by jake powers to get that
out in third base
he's pretty pumped up about it too
in the air on a line boom looks like he
tagged him on the elbow
they're gonna take a look at it
and slide
down he's out
here we go
as jack buck said go crazy folks go
crazy
two down
right now the mariners need him big time
two out a one-run mariner lead
the one-two pitch
skied
infield playable
j.p
ballgame murders win it 4-3 they take
three out of four from the a's they move
to it in a game and a half
of a wild card spot and for the first
time this season they're eight games
beyond 500 and they win yet another
one
run game to go 23-8